أرغب في وضع قائمة بالأماكن
التي تحدث فيها 90٪ من حالات الإصابة بفيروس كورونا في
المنزل ، مكان العمل ، والتجمعات الاجتماعية ، ووسائل النقل العام ،
وسأغادر المنزل خارج المنزل
لأن هذا يحدث بين
زوجك وزوجتك لدى طفلك.  تحصل عليه
منهم ولكن
هناك شيء مشترك بين كل هذه الأماكن الأخرى ، ألا وهو أنهم في
الداخل إلى حد كبير مع مجموعة من الأشخاص الآخرين ،
ما الذي يخبرك ذلك ، فما
نراه تعرفه في الأماكن التي
تقوم بالفعل بتتبع جهات الاتصال
ورسم الخرائط بشكل رائع  ما يحدث مع
انتشار العدوى يرون أن هذه
المساحات المغلقة مع الكثير من الناس
وسوء دوران الهواء يؤدي إلى
انتشار سريع نسبيًا للفيروس بين
الأشخاص المعرضين للإصابة الذين تعرفهم إذا انتهى بك
الأمر في الداخل وهو ما سنعرفه
في بيئة يبدو فيها أن
هناك الكثير من الأشخاص
ولا تشعر بالرضا لأنك تعلم أنهم
المواقف التي يجب عليك تجنبها ،
واستخدم قدميك في مكان آخر.
أنت تعلم أنك تشعر براحة أكبر بالنسبة
لك ، لذا فأنت تعرف أي مكان تعرفه في العمل
تعرف أي بيئة لا
تحافظ على معرفتك بعدد معقول
من الأشخاص الذين يحبون محاولة الحفاظ على تلك
المسافة الاجتماعية التي تعرف أنها لا
تتمتع بتدفق هواء جيد حيث يتواجد كل
شيء  إعادة تدويرها والحصول على الكثير من
الأشخاص ، وإذا كان الجو صاخبًا ، فأنت تعلم أن
هذا مكان أود أن أقول إنني لست بحاجة
إلى التواجد فيه هنا أو لست بحاجة إلى التواجد
هنا لفترة طويلة جدًا ، فهذا مثير للاهتمام إذا
كان الجو صاخبًا  هذا لأنه يعني
أن الكثير من الناس يتحدثون بصوت عالٍ
وربما يضعون المزيد من الفيروسات في الهواء ،
نعم كنت أقرأ بعض الأشياء الممتعة حقًا
حول أن الحديث العادي يطلق
كمية معينة من قطرات الجهاز التنفسي
وكلما تحدثت بصوت أعلى كلما أطلقت المزيد
أنا فقط أضحك نوعًا ما مع
زوجتي في الليلة الماضية أتحدث عن
المتحدثين بصوت عالٍ وكيف يتعين علينا الهروب
منهم الآن ، لذا نعم ، البيئة
التي تحصل فيها على صوت
أعلى ، يجب أن تتحدث بصوت عالٍ وهو ما يعني فقط
سيكون هناك المزيد في الهواء إذا كان
هناك أشخاص مصابون حول
الأبقار ، فهم مثلنا تمامًا ، فهذه
الأبقار تشبهنا تمامًا بطريقة واحدة مهمة ،
وهي طريقة يمكن أن تنقذ الأرواح
أثناء الوباء ، حيث تحتوي هذه الأبقار على
كروموسومات بشرية.  لقد أعطينا البقرة
نظامًا مناعيًا بشريًا جيدًا ، لقد
منحنا البقرة بالتأكيد جزءًا من جهاز
المناعة البشري ، ولذا تأمل هذه الشركة SA B
العلاج الحيوي في ساوث داكوتا
أن تساعد دمائهم في صنع
دواء لمحاربة ko vat19 وإليك كيفية
عملها
باستخدام علماء الهندسة الوراثية
، ابتكروا جنينًا بقريًا يحتوي على أجزاء
من الكروموسومات البشرية ، بحيث يصبح
الجنين عجلًا ثم بقرة ، ثم يتم حقن
جزء غير مُعدٍ من
فيروس كورونا الجديد في تلك البقرة
بسبب الهندسة الوراثية ، حيث
تنتج البقرة أجسامًا مضادة للبشر.
فيروس يتم جمع هذه الأجسام المضادة
من البقرة وبمجرد تنقيتها تصبح
دواءً قد يعمل على مكافحة
فيروس كورونا لدى البشر ، لذا فإن هذه الأبقار
متبرعة بالبلازما مثل الهيوما.  ns الذين
تعافوا من فيروس كورونا وتبرعوا
بالدم ولكن الأبقار لديها
ميزة كبيرة وهي كبيرة ولديها الكثير
من الدم لإعطاء هذا أحد الأسباب
التي اخترناها للماشية لأنها من الواضح
أنها حيوان كبير بالإضافة إلى أنها  يمكن أن
يتبرع بالبلازما ثلاث مرات شهريًا ،
لا يمكن للبشر التبرع إلا مرة واحدة شهريًا ،
تحاول شركة أخرى Regeneron
اتباع نهج مماثل مع الفئران التي تم تصميمها لتكون
لديها أجزاء من جهاز المناعة البشري
، يسمي العلماء الفئران السحرية التي
يستخرجونها واستنساخ أفضل الأجسام المضادة
التي نصنعها حرفيًا  فئران مؤنسنة وراثيًا
وضعناها في الفئران في جينات الجهاز المناعي البشري
بحيث تمتلك هذه الفئران
نظامًا مناعيًا بشريًا إلى حد كبير ،
وتخطط الشركتان لبدء
تجارب إكلينيكية بشرية في وقت مبكر من هذا الصيف ،
إذا سارت الأمور على ما يرام ، فربما يكون هذا الدواء معروضًا
في السوق  لذلك إذا سارت الأمور على ما يرام ، فإننا
نتوقع أن يكون لدينا الدواء في
السوق بحلول أوائل العام المقبل ، بالطبع
ليس هناك ما إذا كان هذا سينجح ولكن
نأمل أن يكون هذا الجزء من البشر  ستلعب الحيوانات
دورًا في إنقاذ الأرواح خلال
الجائحة
التي تبرع بها في الصيف الماضي ، والآن أصبحت
بيرة أو بيضة جاهزة للتطوع طبيًا
مرة أخرى هذه المرة
كخنزير غينيا بشري في تجربة لقاح
مصممة لإصابة متطوعين
بفيروس لم يسبق له مثيل في العالم.  معروف
تمامًا مثل الممرضات والأطباء في
الخطوط الأمامية ، فأنا على استعداد
لتحمل بعض المخاطر على نفسي إذا كان ذلك يعني
أنه يمكننا تجاوز هذا الأمر
كأمة وكعالم شهده عمره 20 عامًا
في نيويورك  ما
يمكن أن يفعله الوباء وقد اشترك عبر الإنترنت
ليكون متطوعًا في تجربة لقاح محتمل
لتحدي الإنسان لـ kovat 19
على عكس تجارب اللقاح الأخرى في
تجربة التحدي ،
سيتم حقن مجموعة من المتطوعين أولاً
بلقاح محتمل وستكون المجموعة الضابطة الثانية
تم حقنها بعلاج وهمي بعد
إتاحة الوقت الكافي
للمتطوعين الذين حصلوا على اللقاح على
أمل بناء المناعة ، فقد
تحدى جميع المتطوعين
الذين لديهم اللقاح ومن لا يملكونه
يُلوث المرشح عمدًا
بفيروس كورونا الذي يحتمل أن يكون
مميتًا ، نعم كل ذلك ، ولكنه قد يكون أيضًا
طريقًا أسرع للحصول على لقاح
فعلي لبقيتنا ، وقد تم تصميمه
لإصابة بعض الأشخاص بالمرض وهذا صحيح
والقصد من ذلك هو جعل بعض الأشخاص في
علامة الشفاه الأقل إصابة بالحكة
عالم الأوبئة بجامعة هارفارد هو أحد العلماء
الذين تكتسب فكرتهم عن استخدام لقاح التحدي
لـ kovat 19 اهتمامًا
من منظمة الصحة العالمية ، وهذا
يمكن أن يوفر شهورًا من الوقت
اللازم لتقييم اللقاح ، والهدف هو
القيام بأسرع ما يمكن.  طريقة مسؤولة
وصالحة علميًا
لتقييم لقاح لقاحات متعددة يمكن
تجربتها في نفس الوقت الضوابط الموضوعة
للرعاية الطبية المناسبة
لجميع المتطوعين وعن طريق اختيار
الشباب
الأصحاء فقط.  ليس صفرًا وهذا هو السبب
في أن التطوع لهذا العمل الإيثاري
ليس مجرد خطر
هو المجهول r  isk يقول الأستاذ روبرت
ريد في جامعة ساوثهامبتون
في المملكة المتحدة إنه يؤيد الفكرة لكنه
يصر على أنه سيكون هناك
إفشاء كامل ، فهذه الحالة
مختلفة ، فنحن غير قادرين على تحديد
المخاطر التي يتعرض لها المتطوع وعندما نتلقى
موافقة مستنيرة من  لهم ، سيتعين
علينا أن نقول لهم أنه لا يمكننا أن نقول
بالضبط ما الذي سيحدث لهم ،
فأنت ستصاب
بشيء لا يوجد
علاج له هذه المرة ، هل
هذا يعطيك توقفًا مؤقتًا بالتأكيد
يعطيني وقفة ولا أريد أن أكون ساذجًا أو
متعجرفًا ولا أريد أن أخفي نفسي
من حقيقة أن هناك خطرًا جادًا
وليس تافهاً على الإطلاق بالنسبة لي للقيام بذلك
على الرغم من مخاطر 16000 شخص من
أكثر من مائة  لقد
وقعت البلدان بالفعل نموذجًا عبر الإنترنت يقول
إنهم مهتمون بأن يصبحوا
متطوعين يشمل رجال الأعمال المخضرمين في الجيش الأمريكي
، الزوج والأب لأربعة أطفال ،
جون جنتل من ألاباما ، نعم أنا أضع
المزيد من الأشخاص المرتبطين بي مباشرة في
خطر أكبر
إذا حدث خطأ ما ولكني أشعر أن الخطر منخفض حتى الآن ، فإن تجربة لقاح التحدي افتراضية ولكن جون لطيف نحلة تزأر و 16000 آخرين يقولون إنهم مستعدون إذا لزم الأمر للمخاطرة إذا كان ذلك يعني أنهم يمكن أن يكونوا جزءًا من إنهاء جائحة كوفات 19 الآن ، أنا مستعد الآن للخروج إلى غرفة الطوارئ ، ولا أعرف تمامًا ما الذي أتوقعه ، فأنت لا تعرف ما الذي تتوقعه من نواح كثيرة ، لقد تحدى فيروس كورونا أطباء الطوارئ مثل مات منذ أن أصاب الأطباء المحيرين مع أعراضه الغامضة ، فإن فيروس كورونا هو فيروس تنفسي يمكن أن ينتشر من خلال الرذاذ مع كل سعال أو كل نفس يكون لديك قطرة تنتقل بعد ذلك إلى أنفك ربما تصل إلى حلقك ثم تنزل في النهاية إلى رئتيك ولكن بعض الناس لديهم مستويات أكسجين منخفضة للغاية و ومع ذلك ، ما زلت أبدو مثلك وأنا لا يمكن تصوره تقريبًا كيف يمكن للناس أن يكونوا مستيقظين ومتنبهين ولديهم مستويات أكسجين نصف طبيعية ويزداد الأمر إرباكًا لأن فيروس الجهاز التنفسي لا يسبب عادةً  فقدان كبير للرائحة
أو النتوءات والآفات الموجودة على القدمين من
الأنف إلى أصابع القدم وتقريبًا كل عضو
بينهما كيف يمكن للخيط المجهري من
الحمض النووي الريبي أن يعيث الكثير في مثل هذا التدمير المتنوع ،
لذلك عندما تأتي
يمكن أن تكون إلى أقصى حد حيث لا يوجد لديهم
النبض بالفعل أو أنهم
يتنفسون بسرعة
كبيرة ونقص الأكسجين بمستوى منخفض جدًا من الأكسجين يمكن أن يكون له
علاقة بالطريقة التي يدخل بها الفيروس عادةً
إلى خلايانا في المقام الأول
الذي تنظر فيه إلى مستقبل ACE 2 الآن
ترى كيف  المسامير على فيروس كورونا
تلتصق بسطح الخلية ،
ومن المعروف أن هذا المستقبل المحدد موجود في
أنسجة الرئة ، ولكن من المعروف أيضًا أنه موجود
في القلب وأجزاء أخرى من الجسم ،
ويبدو أن مستقبل h2 هذا يتم التعبير عنه بشكل
أكثر احتمالية مع تقدم العمر
مستويات أعلى من الإنزيم المحول للأنجيوتنسين - غالبًا ما تكون موجودة عند الرجال
مما قد يفسر أيضًا سبب تعرضهم
للإصابة بشكل أكثر
خطورة مثل وورنال فيجا البالغ من العمر 33 عامًا
والذي أصيب بجلطة دموية مهددة للحياة في
رئتيه بعد ذلك.  في الأرض ،
هناك لغز ما
يفعله لبعض الأطفال على الأقل ثلاثة قتلى الآن
في نيويورك من مرض مع
أعراض مشابهة لمرض كاواساكي
وهي حالة تصبح فيها الأوعية الدموية
ملتهبة لدينا حوالي 100 حالة
من مرض التهابي عند الشباب
الأطفال الذين يبدو أنهم
خلقهم فيروس co vyd ، الأطفال
الذين ظهرت عليهم علامات حالات التهابية ،
أصيبوا بالفعل
بالعدوى منذ أكثر من أسبوعين ، هذا ليس
مثل فيروس آخر رأيته في هذا
الفيروس الصغير الصغير الذي لا يمكن حتى
قتله  لأن الحقيقة هي أنها ليست حية حتى